firstly I'm I'm a player and I feel I've
got a lot of quality which I can bring
to the to the squad so as you said first
and foremost I want to come in and play
and sign help the team and then secondly
once I lay and obviously off filipinas
is stuff to gain experience for Phil
obviously when I do stop playing and I'm
going to the next step
what is it appeals to you about being a
manager at some stage in the future I
mean we've seen some of your Yuengling
teammates Frank Lampard Steven Gerrard
etc have done incredibly well film level
with it with England women now as well
how do you see it at this stage is it
there you know prior playing a Florida
you want to want to follow I think it's
great to see them obviously going into
management but it's on which it's not
just what they do now it's on which I've
always at ambition to do so
and obviously it's great that these
young English managers I get an
opportunity I think I feel over the last
15 20 years
mmm we haven't seen so many play
ex-player England players going into
into management so it's great to see
them doing that but it's one which I've
always wanted to do and when that time
is right of course that's what hopefully
I can move into bore as I said before my
my first aim is to play it's obviously
something which we looked at obviously
for young boys and it's said if my
eldest boy yet it's a crucial time in
his school the school impaired so of
course that's first of all that's the
most important thing in two million its
which we looked at and and then also the
opportunity to to come back here and and
play and obviously I said before because
the next transition in my career so no
it went solely on family it was a few
factors which led me to come back here
I don't know I think that's that's in
the future I think we feel like she
meets the city and say I want to be like
you know of course we all want to be
like the great managers but that's for
the future thing so now we want to
concentrate on on playing and then
obviously coming in January in and try
my best to help the theme was options
there those of the club - and we're
making offers and quieten him about me
but I think I made the decision to
premiere and then that was it so I
wasn't gonna go back on my decision in
so I think the you know the last week
we've we have obviously been trying to -
where how to deal with this DC which
obviously allowed me to go back there
and play also in and then we got to that
decision and here we are today so you
know I think you know as I said before
the opportunity to work with Phillip and
his staff and and then come here and I
think normally that Fabia's accord with
the great ambitions I think you've seen
over the last few years - they're
putting a lot of money into the club -
trying to to take that next step to get
into the Premier League and I felt like
it was a you know a place where I could
come in and use my experience and and
try and help them to achieve the goals
yeah of course it's exciting it's always
great for for any player to see young
players coming through and enjoying the
football I think that's the main thing
for young players as the culture before
if you can get young players on the
pitch enjoying the football ball not
overthinking it and then you have
experienced players around the moving a
time to guide them through through games
through periods and games which which
you will need I needed a in as a young
player and I was lucky enough 12 some
very good experienced players who who
helped me when I was a young player so I
think that's a natural natural rushing
in for
now I'm on the end where and hopefully
help them and guide them